G
AND WELCOME TO TUCKER CARLSON.
>> TONIGHT, SHEILA JACKSON LEE
IS FAMOUS IN WASHINGTON FOR
BEING THE SINGLE MOST OBNOXIOUS
MEMBER OF CONGRESS.
>> NOW, THAT'S A TITLE THAT,
AS YOU CAN IMAGINE, HAS MANY
CONTENDERS.
BUT SHEILA JACKSON STANDS
ALONE.
DON'T YOU KNOW WHO I AM?
SHE ONCE SCREAMED AT A FLIGHT
ATTENDANT IN THE FIRST CLASS
CABIN ON A CONTINENTAL FLIGHT.
I CONGRESSWOMAN SHEILA JACKSON
LEE.
WHERE IS MY SEAFOOD MEAL?
>> IN THE NINETEEN NINETIES
DURING A VISIT TO NASA, SHEILA
JACKSON LEE DEMANDED TO SEE
THE FLAG THAT ASTRONAUTS HAD
PLANTED ON MARS WHEN GENTLY
INFORMED THAT NO HUMAN BEING
HAS EVER BEEN TO MARS BECAUSE
IT'S VERY FAR AWAY.
>> LEE FLEW INTO A RAGE.
SHE ACCUSED NASA OF RACISM
AND POINTED OUT HER MEMBERSHIP
ON THE , QUOTE, SCIENCE
COMMITTEE IN CONGRESS AND SO
ON .
WE COULD SPEND THE ENTIRE HOUR
ON SHEILA JACKSON LEE STORIES,
AND IT'S TEMPTING.
ON CAPITOL HILL, SHE'S KNOWN
AS THE QUEEN AND NOT IN A GOOD
WAY.
>> BUT WHAT'S INTERESTING
IS THAT NOBODY EVER TALKS ABOUT
THE CONGRESS DISTRICT THAT
SHEILA JACKSON LEE SUPPOSEDLY
REPRESENTS.
>> IT'S MOSTLY INNER CITY
HOUSTON, AND IT COULD USE
SOME HELP.
LEE'S DISTRICT HAS A POVERTY
RATE ALMOST TWICE THE NATIONAL
AVERAGE FOR ALL THE USUAL
MARKERS OF CIVILIZATIONAL
DECLINE, HIGH CRIME, BAD
SCHOOLS, LOW SOCIAL COHESION,
DRUGS.
NOW, LEE HAS, QUOTE, SERVED IN
CONGRESS FOR NEARLY 30 YEARS.
BUT IT'S HARD TO THINK OF
A SINGLE THING SHE HAS EVER
DONE TO IMPROVE THE LIVES OF
THE PEOPLE WHO ELECTED HER.
>> SHE DOESN'T SEEM INTERESTED
.
INSTEAD, SHEILA JACKSON LEE HAS
DEVOTED HER ENTIRE
POLITICAL CAREER AND HER ENTIRE
LIFE TO A SINGLE CAUSE.
>> SHRIEKING ABOUT WHITE
RACISM.
THAT'S WHAT SHEILA JACKSON LEE
DOES FOR A LIVING.
>> HERE'S A SELECTION.
INSTITUTIONAL RACISM
AND SYSTEMIC RACISM TAINTS
AND SPOILS US THE WAY THAT
AMERICA TREATS.
IN ONE INSTANCE,
AFRICAN-AMERICANS, IN OTHER
INSTANCES MINORITIES.
>> THE DASTARDLY IMPACTS OF
WHITE NATIONALISM, WHITE
SUPREMACY AND OUTRIGHT RACISM,
RACISM, IS A NATIONAL SECURITY
THREAT.
>> RACISM IS A NATIONAL
SECURITY THREAT.
INSTITUTIONAL RACISM DOES
EXIST.
>> AND UNTIL WE ACCEPT THAT, WE
WILL NOT FINISH OUR JOB, WE
WILL NOT ELECT A CHIEF BIGOT OF
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
>> OUR SYSTEM IS SUCH THAT IT
THEN ALLOWS AMERICANS PEOPLE
TO ACT IN INSTANCES IN A RACIST
MANNER.
>> RACISM, YOU SEE, IS A
NATIONAL SECURITY THREAT
TO NATIONAL SECURITY THREAT.
REALLY.
SHEILA JACKSON LEE, TELL US HOW
RACISM IS A NATIONAL SECURITY
THREAT.
>> SPEAK SLOWLY.
WE'VE GOT PLENTY OF TIME, BUT
OF COURSE, SHE WON'T DO THAT.
SHE'S GOT NO ARGUMENT.
SHE'S GOT NO FACTS.
SHE DOESN'T EVEN HAVE A SINCERE
BELIEF IN WHAT SHE'S SAYING.
IT'S ABSURD.
AND SHE KNOWS IT.
AND BY THE WAY, SHEILA JACKSON
LEE DOESN'T WANT TO PROTECT
A COUNTRY SHE DESPISES FROM
NATIONAL SECURITY THREATS.
WHY WOULD SHE WANT TO DO THAT?
THAT'S NOT THE POINT.
WHAT SHE'S DOING HERE EVERY DAY
IS LEVELING A RACIAL ATTACK,
A BLOOD LIBEL AGAINST AN ENTIRE
GROUP OF AMERICANS WHILE
SIMULTANEOUSLY PRETENDING TO BE
THE VICTIM OF ATTACKS FROM THAT
SAME GROUP.
STOP HITTING ME.
SHE HOWLS AS SHE PUNCHES YOU IN
THE FACE.
IT'S SUCH A COMMON TACTIC AT
THIS POINT, USED CONSTANTLY
BY AL SHARPTON, BY THE ADL,
BY SO MANY OTHERS.
>> YOU MAY NOT EVEN NOTICE IT
ANYMORE, BUT IT'S STILL
DISGUSTING.
IT'S STILL IMMORAL.
IT'S STILL DIVISIVE.
HERE'S JOE BIDEN DOING IT.
>> AND FINALLY, WE'RE
CONFRONTING THE STAINS OF WHAT
REMAINS A DEEP STAIN IN
THE SOUL OF OUR NATION.
HATE IN WHITE SUPREMACY, YOU
KNOW, IS A TOUGH THROUGHLINE OF
SUBJUGATION.
ENSLAVED PEOPLE FROM
OUR EARLIEST DAYS TO THE REIGNS
OF RADICALIZED TERROR, THE KKK,
THE DR. KING BEING ASSASSINATED
AND THE VIOLENT, DEADLY
INSURRECTION IN
THE CAPITAL NINE MONTHS AGO.
IT WAS ABOUT WHITE SUPREMACY,
IN MY VIEW.
SPEAKING OF BLOOD LIBEL,
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT IT
IS PROTESTING THE TWENTY
TWENTY ELECTION RESULT IS THE
SAME AS SLAVERY AS THE KKK.
>> IT'S THE SAME AS MURDERING
MARTIN LUTHER KING.
IT'S ALL WHITE SUPREMACY,
DECLARES JOE BIDEN, WITHOUT
DEFINING A TERM.
NOW, YOU MAY RECALL WHEN
JOE BIDEN SAID THAT YOU
PROBABLY DISMISSED AT THE TIME
AS RIDICULOUS AS THE RANTINGS
OF A PARTISAN.
AND OF COURSE, THAT'S WHAT IT
WAS.
BUT YOU SHOULD ALSO KEEP IN
MIND THAT JOE BIDEN DID NOT SAY
THAT BY ACCIDENT.
IT WASN'T AN AD LIB OFF
THE CUFF.
>> NO, HIS STAFF SIGNED OFF IN
THAT SPEECH.
THEY WROTE THEY READ IT BEFORE
HE READ IT AND THEY WROTE IT
FOR A REASON.
WHEN THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES IDENTIFIES
A THREAT TO THIS COUNTRY, HIS
MANY FEDERAL AGENCIES,
THE BIGGEST IN THE WORLD, SWING
INTO ACTION TO NEUTRALIZE THAT
THREAT.
THAT'S HOW THE SYSTEM WORKS.
AS JOE BIDEN'S STAFF WELL
KNOWS.
>> SO, IN FACT, WHEN JOE BIDEN
LIKENS YOU TO AL AL QAEDA OR
THE , IT'S NOT A SMALL THING AT
ALL.
IT HAS IMPLICATIONS.
>> SO HERE'S SHEILA JACKSON LEE
FROM LAST WEEK IN A NOT
UNRELATED CLIP CALLING FOR
THE RENEWAL OF THE PATRIOT ACT.
>> WHICH I REMEMBER AFTER 9/11,
WHEN WE ALL WORK TOGETHER
TO ENSURE THE PROTECTION OF
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE THROUGH
THE PATRIOT ACT AND DEALING
WITH THE FISA COURTS, WE WORK
TOGETHER BECAUSE TRUTH
IS IMPORTANT.
IT'S KIND OF STRANGE IF YOU
THINK ABOUT IT.
SO WHY WOULD SHEILA JACKSON
LEE, A SELF-DESCRIBED LIBERAL,
FIND HERSELF LAST WEEK PRAISING
THE SECRET GOVERNMENT COURTS
THAT LIBERALS ONCE OPPOSED
PASSIONATELY ON THE GROUNDS
THAT THOSE COURTS COULD BE USED
TO DESTROY THE CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHTS OF AMERICANS WITHOUT
ANYONE KNOWING ABOUT IT?
SECRET COURTS LIBERALS WERE
AGAINST SECRET COURTS, AND NOW
THE CHIEF LIBERAL IN CONGRESS
IS STRONGLY FOR SECRET COURTS.
WHAT'S GOING ON HERE?
WHY?
WELL, BECAUSE THOSE SECRET
COURTS TURN OUT TO BE A HIGHLY
EFFECTIVE WAY TO SILENCE
THE CRITICS OF THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY TO SILENCE THOSE
SO-CALLED WHITE SUPREMACIST
JOE BIDEN'S WAS YELLING ABOUT.
NOT ALL OF THEM, BY THE WAY,
ARE WHITE.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO BE WHITE
TO BE A WHITE SUPREMACIST.
YOU JUST HAVE TO OPPOSE
THE AGENDA AND , OF COURSE,
SHEILA JACKSON LEE KNOWS THAT
VERY WELL.
AND THAT'S WHY SHE WANTS
TO RENEW THE PATRIOT ACT
INDEFINITELY.
AND THERE ARE ENOUGH DUMB
REPUBLICANS THAT SHE MAY
BE ABLE TO , BUT SHEILA JACKSON
WOULD LIKE TO GO A LOT FURTHER
THAN THAT.
LEE IS JUST INTRODUCED A BILL
CALLED THE LEADING AGAINST
WHITE SUPREMACY ACT OF 2020
THREE .
NOW, IT'S NOT AN EXAGGERATION
TO SAY THIS SINGLE BILL WOULD
DO MORE TO CRIMINALIZE SPEECH
PREVIOUSLY, CONSTITUTIONALLY
GUARANTEED SPEECH THAN ANY
OTHER PIECE OF LEGISLATION THAT
HAS BEEN PROPOSED IN THE ENTIRE
HISTORY OF THIS COUNTRY.
>> THAT'S NOT AN OVERSTATEMENT.
AT ALL.
AND TO PROVE IT, WE'RE GOING
TO READ DIRECTLY FROM THE BILL.
HERE IT IS QUOTE, A CONSPIRACY
TO ENGAGE IN WHITE SUPREMACY
INSPIRED HATE CRIME SHALL
BE DETERMINED TO EXIST BETWEEN
TWO OR MORE PERSONS, AT LEAST
ONE OF WHOM PUBLISHED MATERIAL
ADVANCING WHITE SUPREMACY,
WHITE SUPREMACIST IDEOLOGY,
ANTAGONISM BASED ON , QUOTE,
REPLACEMENT THEORY OR HATE
SPEECH THAT VILIFIES OR
IS OTHERWISE DIRECTED AGAINST
ANY NONWHITE PERSON OR GROUP
AND QUOTE, NOW, NOWHERE IN
THE LEGISLATION IS THE TERM
WHITE SUPREMACY OR WHITE
SUPREMACIST IDEOLOGY EVER
DEFINE.
OF COURSE, IT'S NEVER DEFINED.
IT'S LEFT OPEN.
>> IT'S SUBJECTIVE.
ANYTHING CAN BE WHITE
SUPREMACY.
BUT THE BILL DOES SPECIFIC
POINT TO SOMETHING CALLED
REPLACEMENT THEORY.
>> WHITE SUPREMACIST IDEOLOGY.
>> IF YOU ENGAGE IN EITHER
ONE OF THEM, YOU GO TO FEDERAL
PRISON, POSSIBLY FOR A VERY
LONG TIME.
SO ALL THAT'S REQUIRED UNDER
THIS PIECE OF LEGISLATION,
WHICH IS NOT BEEN LEFT OUT OF
CONGRESS YET, ALL THIS REQUIRED
IS THAT YOUR POLITICAL OPINIONS
COULD AS DETERMINED BY A
REASONABLE PERSON, MOTIVATE
ACTIONS BY A PERSON PREDISPOSED
TO ENGAGING IN A WHITE
SUPREMACY INSPIRED HATE CRIME.
SO WHAT WOULD QUALIFY AS A
FELONY UNDER THIS LAW?
>> WELL, VIRTUALLY EVERYTHING
BUT AMONG THEM WOULD
BE POINTING OUT THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY POLITICIANS, INCLUDING
CHUCK SCHUMER, THE LEADING
SENATE DEMOCRAT, HAVE LONGED
BRAGGED THAT THEY ARE FLOODING
THIS COUNTRY WITH IMMIGRANTS IN
ORDER TO CHANGE THE DEMOGRAPHY
,TO MAINTAIN POLITICAL POWER
FOR THEMSELVES.
THEY'VE SAID THAT MANY TIMES.
THEY'VE WRITTEN IT.
THEY BRAGGED ABOUT IT
ON CAMERA.
BUT IF YOU NOTICE IT UNDER THIS
BILL , YOU WOULD BE CRIMINALLY
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE VIOLENT
ACTS OF PEOPLE YOU HAVE NEVER
MET.
AND YOU WOULD GO TO JAIL FOR
TERRORISM.
NOW, WHAT'S MOST INTERESTING
ABOUT THIS BILL IS THAT IT'S
RACE SPECIFIC, NOTHING
AND SHEILA JACKSON LEE
LEGISLATION WOULD APPLY TO ,
SAY, BLACK SUPREMACY OR MURDER
SPREES BY PEOPLE WHO AREN'T
WHITE SUPREMACISTS.
THE MASSACRE IN WAUKESHA, FOR
EXAMPLE.
SO THAT MEANS THAT
DEMOCRATIC PARTY POLITICIANS
CAN CONTINUE TO SAY
WHATEVER THEY WANT
WITH IMPUNITY.
THE FIRST AMENDMENT STILL
APPLIES TO THEM, BUT NOT
TO ANYONE WHO DOESN'T VOTE FOR
THEM.
SO THAT'S THE DEFINITION OF
TYRANNY.
IT'S HORRIFYING.
IT'S A DIRECT ATTACK
ON THE BILL OF RIGHTS, ON OUR
CORE FREEDOMS GUARANTEED BY THE
U.S. GOVERNMENT FOR TWO HUNDRED
AND FIFTY YEARS.
WE SHOULDN'T BE SURPRISED
BY THIS, HOWEVER, BECAUSE IT'S
CONSISTENT WITH WHAT BIDEN HAS
PROMISED AS PROMISES THE DAY HE
GOT INTO OFFICE.
AND THE PROMISE WAS THAT RACE
BLIND JUSTICE, WHICH IS THE
ENTIRE FOUNDATION OF THE RULE
OF LAW IN THE WEST HAS BEEN FOR
CENTURIES, IS DONE.
THE NEW MODEL, SOUTH AFRICA.
THAT'S THE NEW MODEL.
SOUTH AFRICA, A COUNTRY WE
NEVER TALK ABOUT BECAUSE NO
ONE WANTS TO ADMIT WHAT'S
HAPPENED THERE OVER THE PAST
TWENTY NINE YEARS.
BUT ON THE BASIS OF THAT, BIDEN
TRIED TO ALLOCATE FARM AID
ON THE BASIS OF SKIN COLOR.
A FEDERAL JUDGE BLOCKED THAT
PLAN, BUT IT HAS NOT STOPPED
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY BECAUSE NO
ONE'S REPUDIATED THE IDEA.
NO ONE ON THE RIGHT HAS BEEN
BRAVE ENOUGH TO SAY NO.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT CAN
NEVER AWARD OR PUNISH
ON THE BASIS OF SKIN COLOR THAT
IS IMMORAL AND CONTRARY
TO AMERICAN LAW.
AND BECAUSE NO ONE HAS SAID
THAT DEMOCRATS, INCLUDING
SHEILA JACKSON LEE, HAVE
DECIDED THAT THEIR OPPONENTS
ARE TERRORISTS AND THEY'RE
TERRORISTS BECAUSE OF
THEIR RACE.
AND ONCE YOU'RE A TERRORIST,
WHAT DO WE GET TO DO?
WE CAN TAKE ALL YOUR STUFF.
WE GET TO SEIZE YOUR ASSETS.
IT SHOULDN'T SURPRISE YOU.
THAT IS ACTUALLY UNFOLDING IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
ALWAYS THE LEADING EDGE OF
LUNACY.
>> WATCH THIS.
THESE ECONOMISTS I'VE WORKED
ALONGSIDE US OVER THIS PAST
YEAR TO COME UP WITH POTENTIAL
ESTIMATES FOR WHAT REPARATIONS
IN THE FORM OF COMPENSATION OR
CASH PAYMENTS CAN LOOK LIKE FOR
AFRICAN-AMERICANS.
THAT FIVE HUNDRED BILLION
DOLLAR NUMBER REPRESENTS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA'S
MAXIMUM CULPABILITY FOR RACIST
RED MINING PRACTICES.
AND THAT NUMBER REPRESENTS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA MAX.
MY ABILITY IT IS NOT A FINAL
RECOMMENDATION COMING OUT OF
THE TASK FORCE.
FINAL RECOMMENDATIONS DO NOT
COME OUT UNTIL JULY ONE .
2020 THREE KNOW EVERYTHING
ABOUT THIS, OF COURSE, IS BAD
AND WRONG, NOT JUST IN
PRACTICE, BUT IN PRINCIPLE, BUT
IN PRACTICE.
IT SETS UP AN INCENTIVE THAT
THE WHOLE COUNTRY CAN HAVE
TO GRASP WITH FAIRLY SOON.
WE'VE ALREADY BEEN TOLD THAT
YOU CAN CHANGE YOUR  OR
IMMUTABLE CHARACTERISTIC JUST
BY WISHING.
AND SO MEN CAN BECOME WOMEN.
WOMEN CAN BECOME MEN .
WHY THEN CAN'T PEOPLE CHANGE
THEIR RACE?
THAT'S A SINCERE QUESTION THAT
IS WAVED AWAY IS RIDICULOUS.
BUT IT'S NOT ANY
MORE RIDICULOUS THAN CHANGING
YOUR .
IN FACT, IT'S THE SAME.
>> SO UNDER LAWS LIKE THIS,
THERE IS A HUGE INCENTIVE
TO CHANGE YOUR RACE BECAUSE YOU
GET PAID FOR DOING THAT.
WHAT ARE WE GOING TO DO ABOUT
THAT?
>> BUT WHAT'S INTERESTING
AND SADLY, SADLY PREDICTABLE
IS THAT AS POLITICIANS IN
CALIFORNIA AND THE REST OF
THE COUNTRY DECIDE HOW THEY'RE
GOING TO LOOT THE TREASURY,
THE NAME OF RACIAL JUSTICE,
THE COMMUNITIES THEY SUPPOSEDLY
SERVE ARE FALLING APART.
IN REAL, TANGIBLE, MEASURABLE
WAYS.
>> PEOPLE ARE DYING.
AXIOS, FOR EXAMPLE, REPORTS
THAT CARJACKINGS IN DC HAVE
RISEN FOR THE FIFTH STRAIGHT
YEAR.
ASK ANYONE WHO LIVES THERE
AS THE D.C. COUNCIL CANDIDATE
WHO WAS CARJACKED IN BROAD
DAYLIGHT A YEAR AGO.
>> A VEHICLE STOLEN FRIDAY MAY
BE LINKED TO MULTIPLE CRIMES IN
NORTHEAST, INCLUDING THE MURDER
OF NINETEEN YEAR OLD DEVIN
BREWER.
THERE WAS A DRIVE BY SHOOTING
ON CENTRAL AVENUE NORTHEAST.
BOTH VICTIMS SURVIVED.
LOOK OUT FOR THE SAME.
HYLANDER WENT OUT OVER POLICE
RADIO.
THE PLATES ON THE CAR APPEAR
TO MATCH THE BURGUNDY.
HIGHLANDER USED TO CARJACK
A D.C. COUNCIL CANDIDATE AT GUN
POINT.
NATE FLEMING WAS AT A GAS
STATION ON NANNIE HELEN
BURROUGHS AVENUE NORTHEAST.
HE SAYS WHEN THE SUSPECT PULLED
A GUN, HE GAVE UP THE KEYS,
THEN WENT INTO THE CONVENIENCE
STORE TO CALL 911 ONE .
HE SAYS ONE OF THE GUYS CAME IN
TO STOP HIM FROM DOING THAT,
CHASING HIM OUT OF THE STORE.
>> SO INSTEAD OF DOING ANYTHING
ABOUT THAT IN, THE LEADERS ARE
DOING WHAT SHEILA JACKSON LEE
DOES.
SHRIEKING ABOUT WHITE RACISM
AS IF THAT'S THE PROBLEM OR
EVEN A RELATED PROBLEM OR
THERE'S NOTHING TO DO
WITH CARJACKINGS.
>> AS FOR ACTUAL CARJACKINGS,
THAT ARE KILLING PEOPLE, MAKING
TAXPAYERS LEAVE DC TARIFA,
EVERYONE IN THE CITY.
>> WELL, THE D.C. CITY COUNCIL
HAS JUST PASSED A BILL THAT
WILL LIGHTEN THE PUNISHMENT FOR
CARJACKING AS WELL AS OTHER
VIOLENT CRIMES.
SO HERE'S WHAT YOU HAVE AT
THE SAME TIME THAT SHEILA
JACKSON LEE WOULD LIKE TO MAKE
IT A , QUOTE, HATE CRIME,
A FELONY FOR DISAGREEING
WITH HER.
HER COMPATRIOTS IN D.C.
AND ACROSS THE COUNTRY ARE
MAKING IT EASIER FOR YOU TO GET
KILLED BY AN ACTUAL CARJACKER
NON-NARCOT